[Música]
[Aplausos]
con esta frase popular de nuestra
cultura gracias a esa primera persona
burla de ninjas tiene un backstage de un
concierto y qué bueno ahora se utiliza
diferentes formas para un arte una forma
retórica
preguntarse algo que en realidad no está
plano que tenga respuesta yo lo que hice
en mi primer conexión presente
la forma de modo más importante de del
país interés mundiales
también es sumamente importante que una
licencia de lo que todos reconocemos
como
y méxico
me tocó vivir de una u otra forma en
quebrar lo de ésta el resurgimiento y
están en las dos etapas de ella ahora
con todas las habilidades de redes
sociales y de la facilidad que tenemos
para comunicarnos y de expresar algo y
entonces utilice esta claridad con el
afán de burlarme mochito de beni de la
historia detrás de amor la línea que
como muchos sabe de pronto en menos de
dos semanas el nombre empezó a sonar
gracias a una verificación es y llegada
y búsqueda de la moda sin una carrera
al menos reconocida y presentarla
coleccionando de la plataforma de arte
moral entonces así 2006 y les voy a
contar un poquito de mi historia
para poder llegar a utilizar esa frase
los comienzos no por fáciles tenemos más
de 13 años en la industria de
procesamiento o el desarrollo textil
para hacer moda no para hacer artículos
con ellos
la historia fue complicada estudie en
responder y sabes
básicamente me entré a la universidad
justo antes de irme estudio en españa en
producción musical
siempre como relacionado con las artes
descubrir de muy chico
el diseño pintar la arquitectura me
llama mucho la atención
y ya te seguiré estudiando y delante con
explicación encuentro con disposición y
bellas artes que básicamente cumplía
todos los requisitos para poder tener la
universidad y este era tener un poquito
de todas las carreras de diseño todos
las disciplinas de diseño pueden llegar
a existir porque al final yo sabía que
quería este modo siempre estudió la
música y la moda en las dos caras que
más me llamaba la atención y bueno pues
se volvió bien interesante y annecy para
tocar la puerta mejor director en cuanto
a patricia que yo ver con mucho cariño
me abrió la puerta a dos de retiras con
la bolsa en el hombro y un suspiro
profundo y me dio cinco minutos tiempo a
explicarme que una escuela muy
disciplinaria la única escuela que tenía
un programa de estudios manual puedes
llevar gas industrial en textil y al
final es descansar algunas veces
entonces básicamente desarrollo me
convenció de quedarme
y muchísimas cosas conocían
con quien fundó una compañía llamada
pasión ardiente y soluciones a la
historia la compañía tan fácil
obviamente iniciamos con un proyecto de
la escuela en el cual queríamos hacer
moda
y crear en confeccionar y desarrollar en
el campo de distribución etcétera no
está funcionando el país
como hoy en día está empezando
y la realidad es que esto pues gracias a
dios ha sucedido por la permeabilidad
que tenemos de las redes sociales hoy en
día por la tecnología ya no dependemos
de monopolios no dependemos de una
empresa que tenga una estructura que sea
para darnos digamos que la promoción que
estamos buscando en este momento
y pues me topé con ese quebranto de la
industria de la moda en parís el nombre
de fashion week había sido prohibido
utilizarse en el país no habían las
formas de moda surgieron hay 23
elementos que es organizado pero todos
tienen un enfoque meramente social era
un lugar donde cada seis meses la crema
y nata de la sociedad y las que tomaban
una copa estaba en una pasarela gloria
se retira mente se quedaba cuatro meses
más sin hacer nada de su vida al menos a
su vez historias más cercanas que yo
tuve con las personas que conozco hay
dos hijos contemporáneos de de ellos no
en esa época y pues es quebrantado y
triste después de la primera exposición
dentro donde no presentando
de nuestras piezas dentro del marco y en
el medio del evento
salgo de allí y creo que este no es el
camino creo que si seguimos acá nunca
vas a la industria y en el país nunca
vamos a cambiar la perspectiva y
deberíamos demostrar la forma de hacerlo
diferente qué es lo que hace falta para
un diseñador de modas infraestructura
desarrollar tus diseños el despacho es
el personal de la proveeduría en méxico
para diseñadores que prevén se es
sumamente complicado porque en realidad
no existe
la mayoría de los proveedores están
causas producir en masa volumen y de
pronto acercarte como diseñador
independiente a producir algo y sobre
todo con los volúmenes que diseñadores
dependiente puede manejar por la
capacidad de venta que tiene de
expansión y en ese momento muchísimo de
puntos de distribución en ese momento
había 34 tiendas de moda la ropa de 12
años
y los pastores han desarrollado un
informes corporativos estilizados en
publicidad que protegen durante los hace
hace dos años los últimos diez años de
mi vida eso es lo que estuviesen
desarrollen campañas para diferentes
marcas desde jerzy stuhr chains o car
por diabetes y motorola excelencia de la
hélice desde la playera polo para el
promotor de un evento de marketing
offline o lo que estuviera solicitando
el cliente hasta desarrollo de sastrería
y el paladar informes de inauguración de
pierre chance excelente de venganza dos
hermanos el pasamos por muchos procesos
que nos parecen reunimos a
desarrollarnos dentro del industria
principalmente con materiales nacionales
[Música]
los procesos son muy artesanales y mucha
gente me pregunta por qué no sea
coleccionando tantas marcas
es una manera de actuar y me gusta
esta marca al final ya tenía como un
tipo de comunicación nosotros trabajar
ir a la conclusión del tipo de marca que
tener en serio del tipo de público que
la tenía que experimentar y usualmente
al final ese es el es el resultado del
trabajo previo que vivimos con el
proceso y que además me ha ayudado
muchísimo para hoy presentar
hardware en soft
no me gustaría resumiendo que trabajé
muchísimo para llegar a este por la
realidad es que lo hemos hecho y nos
hemos comprometido con el musculosos
comprometido con nuestros socios
comerciales y nos hemos comprometido con
las pruebas de las cosas que sentía una
de las cosas que más nos representan muy
fuerte es que tenemos un nivel de
compromiso como si fueran para nosotros
mismos nos busca en realidad público nos
gusta atender a nuestros clientes
directamente nos gusta estar pendientes
de nuestro negocio
y hemos vivido de hacerlo desde un día
de las costureras con todas las personas
que trabajan con nosotros etc
de madrugada han venido porque no estaba
llegando a tiempo y la verdad es parte
de la evolución
y dice esto
después de estos 10 años trabajar con mi
socia y de haber tenido fashion art y
solo social ha desarrollado
wang dalin clima vuelta
de la noche de manera decidimos
separarnos y la verdad es que siempre en
un poco de presión me di cuenta que no
era fácil después de haber tenido una
vida conjunto ya haber crecido no había
experimentado miles de cosas con con una
persona especialista en esto se acabó
pero de lo que se estaba seguro y ahora
es que 23 pláticas con mis personas más
gente nos ayudaron a confirmar es que yo
no quería encargando nada de lo que ya
habíamos hecho me quedaba con todo el
conocimiento me queda por toda la
evolución que hemos tenido y con todo lo
que yo podía hacer con eso que había
desarrollado el trabajo
a lo largo de sus años
[Música]
esto sucedió en 2016
por el mes de agosto y va a septiembre
uno de mis bienes más importantes
y con mayor relación que tener meses
y les dioses que nos separan y empezar
de cero que hacemos otra de las cosas
importantes del por qué está esta
conferencia se llama el sistema son que
este nombre lo desarrollamos unos días
después de haber conocido a esta persona
que ahora es mi socio y que literalmente
me sacó de un bache creativo y mental de
italia porque yo decía digo dedicarme a
esto
sigo haciendo uniformes pues en alguien
más desarrollado y diseñado si hay
alguien que estuvimos el sueño de ser
después de presentar una colección es
como el top
cada vez que no tiene mucho esfuerzo
pero pero es lo que estás esperanzas
[Música]
y
era el camino correcto para para saber
que la moda no era solamente presentarse
en la pasarela que hay niños de negocios
y entonces que te pueden hacer súper
feliz y yo puedes hacer una alianza
entre la música y la moda era algo que
me podía el ecólogo inter me cambió la
vida representa américa doramas compañía
junto con el hijo
y más en la parte creativa
pero con la intención
principalmente
cambiar la perspectiva de lo que da la
vida teorías reales y conciertos y
regresan a las normas independientes de
lo que estaban invirtiendo para darnos
felicidad con la vista por llamarlo de
alguna forma era un circuito en el cual
si nombramos la música
éxito compraba largarse oficial seguía
esperando informar a quienes quieran
preparando o producción musical que tú
querías escuchar no entonces me parece
un proyecto súper bonito y como ya les
dije en relación a la música y la moda
de hacer una alianza entre las dos es
una de las cosas que más ha marcado mi
vida
hoy por hoy dentro del mercado alemán
seguimos haciendo espero porque todas
las métricas internacionales y colaborar
con las bandas más importantes del mundo
quería yo
y bueno a raíz de eso
nuestro primer viaje a los ángeles para
tocar puertas con algunos clics a los
pies haya hemos distribuido el producto
pero que no hayas tenía un acercamiento
formal para mostrarles todas nuestras
capacidades de diseño y de producción
me encuentro porque en la pasión que
tenían todos estos clips por trabajar
con gente méxico r no regularmente estos
estos tienes trabajo con proveedores
chinos y pues los que ha trabajado con
proveedores chinos sabrán que la
comunicación el cambio de horario la
distancia siempre son un problema
entonces más allá de sólo esto vive la
cercanía con méxico y del idioma y de
los tiempos para entregar productos y
nos emocionaba mucho ver como siempre
había mexicano involucrado en los
procesos atractivos en el diseño en las
industrias que hoy -por de formar parte
de la cultura popular y que además forma
parte de nuestra vida
vamos a hablar de música y alice y
deberes muy inspirado alberto de toda la
cantidad de casas con seriedad porque
además íbamos literalmente con dos pesos
en la bolsa nuestras maletas llenas de
muestras y muchas ilusiones en una en un
fin de semana que teníamos
aproximadamente dos juntas tal vez tres
puntas del mismo como 10 y realizamos
con proyectos asegurados
entre ellos vodafone y de regreso diseñó
esto que es lo que me puso donde estoy
yo quiere hacer un informe pero
representar para todos los colaboradores
de mente adoran y tirantes a grandes
estrellas después tengo pocos disputan
contarles pero en realidad debemos
involucrar ilustradores gráficos
nacionales para poder arrancar un
poquito a la piratería pueden tener el
mismo producto que nosotros y todos
estos ilustrados nos representan a nivel
internacional es importante para mí
tener un informe que hablara de méxico y
que les hablar en un idioma en el cual
el mundo se entera de piedad que se
trata principios de hacerse una frase
sumamente discutible sabíamos que iba a
haber mucha gente enojada molesta de
entrada porque en inglés no porque 17
porque en ese contexto porque tiene una
connotación negativa en cuanto a la
palabra no y la realidad es que delgada
pues no lo diseñamos con el afán de
agradarle al público nacional de un
informe interno pero ya que pasó tenemos
muchos proyectos para poder hablar bien
de ella
para el mundo que somos innovadores
y hacemos las cosas bien que los
necesitamos nos unimos estamos unos con
otros
tenemos la capacidad de levantar un país
después de un terremoto de una manera
impresionante
teniendo en extremo gracias a messi
widget hoy estamos con verdad ahora más
yo como no ha ido ni tardes donde
nosotros a tener la oportunidad de
acercarnos al público y todo esto con el
afán de hacer crecer industrias pero
edad a las generaciones que vienen un
poquito más de facilidad para que
podamos crecer y para que podamos
realmente tener
una industria a nivel internacional
posicionada y que nos represente el país
pero una manera diferente
recientemente esta última colección
fashion week
iker enseñárselos porque al final esta
parte de trabajo y de comunicación sin
prestados
en mi mente de mi vida y estas pruebas
de las colecciones con más trabajo que
hemos tenido y donde además involucramos
a un chorro hay gente que es creativa
que ha desarrollado ahora es amante de
lo exacto haciendo que se suman
proyectos de este tipo y sabemos una
serie de visuales creíbles y además que
la oportunidad internacional
donde desarrollen un chelsea que además
es un chorro hablar de porque no
solamente el esfuerzo de la empresa es
que
que se es la primera colaboración en
méxico que se desarrolla en méxico sino
que está concierto en el país desde
encontrarte para seguir impulsando las
crisis de las textiles entonces los
buenos es a parte de seguir trabajando
seguir colaboraba seguir presentando
gente importante y por último va a ser
concluyente hoy me gustaría cerrar esto
platicándoles un poquito en mi
experiencia
y cuesta aquí en mi socio me encantaría
darle las gracias personal
[Aplausos]
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]